bonjour à toutes et à tous ces paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux at on découvert de l'adn de
dinosaures voici le titre de l'article
qui propose de répondre à cette question
donc article paru dans nationale sayan
review evidence of protein ce chromosome
and chemical marc dienna une
exceptionnelle priseur dinosaur
cartilage des preuves de protéines de
chromosomes et de marqueurs de l'adn
exceptionnellement préservé dans du
cartilage de dinosaures donc déjà il
faut savoir que le cartilage c'est un
tissu mou ça préserve pas souvent
surtout dans un truc qui à 70 millions
d'années comme annie paquereau or 70
millions d'années on est en amérique du
nord et on a du cartilage donc ça c'est
quand même une découverte assez
exceptionnel rien qu'en soit le
cartilage mais at on découvert de l'adn
dedans at on découvert des chromosomes
dedans ça c'est la grande question et
même avant de commencer j'ai envie de
dire c'est une grande question certes
mais pourquoi parce que au-delà de
l'effet jurassic park
honnêtement qui ici a une idée de ce que
ça implique
si on trouve de l'adn de dinosaures au
delà de l'effet jurassic park c'est à
dire commencez pas à me chanter des
résurrections de dinosaures vraiment je
vous le demande quelle est l'importance
d'une telle découverte
valve a tapé dans les commentaires taper
dans les commentaires trichait pas lé
pas voir le reste de la vidéo
taper dans les commentaires ce que vous
pensez être l'importance d'une telle
découverte du point de vue scientifique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire du point de
vue scientifique qu'est ce que ça
implique
et bonne chance bonne chance je vais
vous le dire je vais vous le dire c'est
à la fin de l'article mais mais voilà au
delà de l'effet jurassic park pourquoi
est ce que ça nous intéresse
bref donc déjà la case la bonne question
c'est avant même avant même de toute
façon de se demander quelle est
l'importance de la découverte de l'adn
at on vraiment découverte de l'adn dans
ses dents c'est typique rosa rebond
alors j'ai surligner quelques passages
importants faut savoir que je ne suis
pas bio
molécule aris tout
biochimiste tout ce que vous voulez donc
mon interprétation de cet article est
quand même limité
voilà ma capacité d'interprétation de
cet article est quand même limité je ne
comprends pas tous les gros mots qui
sont utilisés dans cet article bon
évidemment j'essaye de me renseigner
mais je prétends pas tout connaître non
plus en bio en biochimie
bref donc voilà il présente ipaq rose or
c'est un petit bout de crâne un petit
bout de l'occiput de l'arrière du crâne
dans ce petit bout de crâne
il y à des contres au site enfin il ya
deux il ya du cartilage et dans ce
cartilage
il y aurait des condos site c'est-à-dire
des cellules de cartilage préserver et
ça c'est donc c'est ce qu'on voit là ça
c'est le petit bout de crâne et à
l'intérieur ils ont fait des sections
dans l'eau sein des sections ultrafin et
ils voient des cellules de cartilage et
ils ont même trouvé une cellule de
cartilage qui a l'air d'être en train de
se diviser vous voyez là et donc dans
cette cellule qui a l'air d'être en
train de se diviser il ya ces amas qui
pourraient être des chromosomes
voilà donc la partie déjà là on a
couvert la partie chromosomes du truc
voilà protéines bas cartilage s'il ya
des tissus mous ya forte ya forcément
des protéines
là on vient de couvrir la partie
chromosomes il reste plus que l'adn
maintenant la question c'est est-ce que
ces chromosomes contiennent est ce que
c'est vraiment des chromosomes et du
coup est ce qu'ils contiennent des
molécules la dnc présumé chromosome ils
ont fait des tests
ils ont utilisé ce qu'ils appellent des
marqueurs et là c'est ça qui est
important c'est dans ce paragraphe la
voile à isolation de l'adn décombres au
site
donc dans ce paragraphe là ils ont
utilisé des marqueurs qui s'appelle du
pays et d'api voit la pomme de reinette
ici et puis pomme d'api qui est là donc
ils ont utilisé pomme de reinette et pom
d'api qui sont deux marqueurs
spécifiques de l'adn et là il faut être
très spécifique c'est pour ça que j'ai
surligner cette phrase en jaune ils ont
ces marqueurs sont des marqueurs
chimiques cohérent avec de l'adn ou
comment on pourrait traduire consistant
dans cette consistante dans ce contexte
qui sait des marqueurs chimiques
possiblement associé à de l'adn quoi
vraiment donc il n'ya pas il n'ya pas
non plus de 100% de certitudes
normalement en quand on fait ça sur du
matériel moderne voilà ça s'accroche à
l'adn ça veut pas forcément dire que sur
du matériel dégradé ça va forcément
marché voilà sur du matériel qu'à 70
millions d'années qui a subi des
modifications chimiques
ça veut pas forcément dire que ça va
marcher et surtout ce ne sont pas des
marqueurs spécifiques à l'adn d'une
espèce en particulier c'est l'adn
point barre donc n'importe quel adn et
c'est là que c'est important
c'est vrai que c'est important parce
qu'effectivement quand il envoie ses
marqueurs bas effectivement ils
regardent le condroz site et hop les
marqueurs ils ont bien marqué ce qu'il
fallait marquer voilà la pomme de
reinette ici le pom d'api et là et pouf
ils ont marqué il ya du marquage si ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya des agglomérats
de quelque chose qui est cohérent
consistante avec de l'adn
donc ça veut dire que possiblement il
s'agit d' adn et ça c'est formidable ça
c'est formidable déjà parce que ba de la
dn2 de la dn2 de 70 millions d'années la
com com et 17 leur dans jurassic park de
la dl de l'adn paléolithique 200
millions d'années va falloir qu'on fasse
des analyses de séquences de jurassic
park pour relever les moments où ils
disent des choses intéressant et les
moments ils disent des choses un peu
moins voilà la conclusion de l'article
ce qui est important c'est qu'ils ont
ces mots donc ils ont effectivement des
marqueurs cohérent avec de l'adn qui
s'accrochent à leur chondrocytes de
dinosaures ceci étant dit il précise
bien que il faudra séquencé ce matériel
car ni pomme de reinette ni pomme d'api
ne sont capables de confirmer qu'il
s'agit de matériel que ce tas des haines
et dinosauriens de par son origine c'est
important ça et ça c'est ultra important
comparé ça maintenant vous avez
certaines
entendu ça dans les journaux l annonce
de la découverte de dingsdag dn2
dinosaures vous avez vu ça dans les
dents les médias vous avez vu ça sur
internet vous avez certainement même vu
ça à la télé
comparez cette phrase à ce qui a été dit
à la télé adn de dinosaures non non nous
avons utilisé des marqueurs cohérent
avec de l'adn sur une cellule que nous
supposons venir d'un dinosaure et on a
trouvé que ces marqueurs cohérent à
l'adn ont réagi par contre ça veut pas
dire que l'adn en question et de l'adn
de dinosaures et ça c'est important ça
veut dire imaginer que pendant la
décomposition vous avez des bactéries ou
des champignons qui investissent vos
cellules pour commencer à les manger là
bas voilà si ça se trouve c'est l'adn de
ces bestioles la kiss et fossilisés et
qui est resté ils sont assez pomme de
reinette pays et spécifique des cellules
mortes
donc ils peuvent pas avoir détecté une
bactérie moderne voilà déjà il ya au
moins ça qui est exclu ce n'est pas de
l'adn de bactéries moderne donc si c'est
de la dnc forcément de l'adn ancien
après ça veut pas forcément dire qu'il a
qu'il a soit 70 millions d'années ça
peut vouloir dire qu'il ya peut-être il
ya eu un dépôt de matières organiques
entre le moment de la fossilisation et
la collecte peut-être que quand le
matériel a été co mark j'allais dire
peut-être que quand le matériel a été
collecté il ya eu contamination mais bon
sachant qu'ils ont extrait les cellules
d'une section
normalement il n'y a pas eu
contamination voilà puis encore une fois
ci c'était contamination peut-être que
ce serait trop récent pour que pomme de
reinette réagissent mais encore une fois
n'étant pas moi-même biochimiste je peux
pas savoir à quel point quand ils disent
que pomme de reinette là il
il réagit que aux cellules mortes je
sais pas morte depuis combien de temps
quoi donc bref on a de l'adn il est
possiblement vieux de 70 millions
d'années et il est possiblement
d'origine dinosaur yen mais il n'y a
aucun moyen de le prouver pour l'instant
il faudra c'est quand c'est cet adn il
faudra arriver déjà le sortir de là ce
qui va pas être évident et il va falloir
le séquencé pour y arriver alors c'est
ça ouvre des portes formidable la
possibilité de pouvoir trouver de l'adn
vieux de 70 millions d'années mais
quelles sont ses portes
me direz-vous bah oui bah déjà ça va
être un analyse phylogénétique des
dinosaures parce que quand on voit un le
merdier cas foutu les analyses kung fu
tu les analyses adn des mammifères
modernes sur leur phylogénie 1
on a découvert que notre classification
a été complètement pété en regardant
l'adn des mammifères il n'est pas
impossible que maintenant qu'on peut
trouver de l'adn de dinosaures peut-être
on puisse avoir une fille le génie
complètement pété des dinosaures c'est
pas impossible
et surtout surtout ça applique et bas
que ce qu'on croit connaître de la
fossilisation c'est ce petit paragraphe
là et tout faux enfin c'est pas tout
faux mais c'est loin d'être vrai on
considère globalement que quelque chose
et fossilisés quand il ya plus de
matières organiques dedans et
généralement on a un peu arbitrairement
considéré que cette limite c'était un
million d'années en gros même si même si
c'est pas vrai il ya des cas où ça va
beaucoup plus vite et il ya des cas où
ça va beaucoup plus lentement puisque 70
millions d'années après on trouve encore
du cartilage donc de la matière
organique cartilage qui contient encore
des chondrocytes donc des cellules et
chondrocytes qui contiendrait peut-être
même encore de l'adn du dinosaure et pas
d'un champignon et ça et ça ça ça ça
repousse beau de beaucoup la limite de
ce qu'on prétend appeler un fossile donc
maintenant revenait à ma question de
départ quelles sont les implications de
la découverte de l'adn de dinosaures
tous ceux qui ont séché bas c'est normal
vous êtes en bonne santé
tous ceux qui avaient réussi à trouver
les deux trucs que je viens de vous dire
bravo
grand bravo parce que c'était pas
évident c'était une question très
difficile et c'est souvent le cas quand
on fait des grandes annonces comme ça
c'est ouais mais pourquoi c'est
important
voilà voilà ce qui est important parce
que on a peut-être le matériau qui
servira à réécrire complètement la
phylogénie des dinosaures et en a
peut-être une nouvelle façon d'envisager
la fossilisation voilà et donc leurs
conclusions leurs grandes conclusions et
finalement leur grande conclusion c'est
quand même de rappeler que la
contamination est très peu plausible
puisque on est quand même en train de
regarder dans une cellule de cartilage
enfin ils ont trouvé de l'adn dans une
cellule de cartilage à l'intérieur d'un
cartilage d'un dinosaure donc ce serait
quand même vachement bizarre que cette
cellule est de l'adn d'autre chose que
d'une cellule de cartilage de dinosaures
voilà c'est pas impossible la
contamination on a déjà piégé plus d'un
donc affaire à suivre
on verra dans le futur mais voilà
enthousiasme a tempéré et surtout
réfléchir à chaque fois à ce qu'on est
vraiment en train de regarder quel et
l'éducation les applications de ces
découvertes un follow up maintenant sur
oculi dante avis le plus petit dinosaure
du monde le plus petit dinosaure du
monde découvert dans l'ombre birman qui
ne serait du coup même pas un dinosaure
voire même pas du tout un art cause or
d'après cet article donc c'est vraiment
un follow up de mon précédent paléo news
de la semaine dernière où déjà je
présentais certains caractères docu lieu
dante avis basé sur cette hauteur là
d'ailleurs wei wang
c'est lui qui avait écrit l'article an
chinois qui est dans le que je présente
dans le précédent paléo news donc voilà
basé sur cet article y avait des
caractères docu lui dans ta vie ce qui
dot qui ne collait pas avec une
identification comme un oiseau et même
comme une identification comme un
archosaures et ben là ils viennent de
décrire un article qui était
et qui étaient accessibles en ligne
merci à hugo laine de me l'avoir
renvoyée parce que je pense pas que
j'aurais trouvé tout seul celui là
honnêtement
donc merci hugo est donc cet article il
se résume très bien par ces images donc
voilà les directement aux images hop
voilà c'est des grosses d'image de très
grosses ssii malou et la trop petite m
c'est pas évident c'est pas bien
voilà donc voici le crâne deux
occupantes avis est donc qu'est-ce qui
fait cocu lui dans ta vie ce n'est pas
un oiseau bat déjà la présence d'un faux
ramène pinéale il ne se voit pas sur la
surface reconstruit en 3d a oui un truc
tout bête un truc tout bête mais il ya
une grosse discussion sur le paléo news
précédente dans les commentaires sur la
possible malhonnêteté intellectuelle des
gens qui ont décrit aux curieux dans ta
vie au moins d'une personne au moins un
des auteurs qui a écrit au cully nantes
avis est accusé de malhonnêteté
intellectuelle
quand je vois ça donc les des gens qui
ne sont pas les gens qui ont produit les
images parce qu'il a fallu qu'ils
demandent l'accès aux images valent à
ozcan ce que vous voyez là ce sont des
tranches de city scan donc ce sont des
tranches de docu lui dans ta vie ce qui
aurait été réalisée virtuellement grâce
à des rayons x et ils ont utilisé ces
tranches pour reconstruire
voilà un modèle 3d documente avis quand
je vois que le modèle 3d de cet article
qui n'est qu'un petit follow up au gros
articles qui a été lui publié dans
nature et qu'il a de meilleur image que
l'article de nature's ça fait quand même
vachement douter de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle des auteurs du premier
article
parce que là ces images là elles sont en
couleur et elles sont plus claires j'ai
enfin on voit mieux les structures
anatomiques sur ces images là que sur
l'article original quoi et ça c'est pas
normal ça c'est pas normal déjà de base
bref et donc ouais sur ceux sur cette
reconstruction en 3d du crâne fait à
partir des des scans donc
des images à rayons x on voit dans cette
région du club du crâne qui a un trou
trou qu'ils interprètent comme le
foramen pinéale et le foramen pinéale il
ya aucun archosaures qui ne l'a jamais
eue il ya quelques arrco zory forme
bazzo du trias qui peuvent en avoir un
mais les archosaures les vrais
archosaures le groupe dans lequel on
trouve les crocodiles les dinosaures les
ptérosaures les oiseaux celui là il n'ya
jamais jamais de faux ramène pinéale
c'est un truc de reptiles ectothermes le
foramen pinéale et encore même y'a pas
que quand je dis ectothermes ça veut
dire à sang froid pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas et mêmes certains
reptiles à sang froid comme les
crocodiles et tortues et les serpents
par exemple n'ont pas de faux ramène
pinéale même si l'on à sang froid donc
c'est vraiment qu'une poignée de
reptiles qui ont ça notamment certains
squamates comme les lézards donc le
varan de komodo info ramène pinéale les
les iguanes ont un fort amène pinéale
les petits lézards des mûrons défaut
ramène pinéale voilà si vous vivez dans
le sud vous avez déjà vu des lézards des
murs donc ils ont un foramen pinéale si
vous faites une petite coupe là au
milieu de leurs têtes
vous verrez la même chose donc donc déjà
fort amène pinéale ça exclut que c'est
un archosaures ce qui est tout à fait
cohérent avec le fait que ici là entre
la narine et l'oeil
il n'y a absolument aucune fausse en
théorie terre voilà donc fo santé
orbitaire qu'on devrait voir normalement
chez un archosaures et shean archosaures
on devrait aussi voir une barre ici
poste temporal donc vous avez la fosse
temporal supérieur la fosse temporal
inférieur et elle est ouverte
la fosse temporal inférieur il n'y a pas
de dos là qui ferme la fosse temporal
chez les archosaures vous devriez avoir
ça et il n'y a pas et ça encore une fois
c'est un caractère qu'on retrouve très
souvent chez les squamates donc chez les
petits lézards et ceux qui finit
totalement de planter le clou du
cercueil
du cercueil documente avis en tant que
quoi zoo c'est la présence de dents sur
le palais donc sur le palais et sur le
pts et rigaud id donc les dents sur le
palais vous imaginez vous si vous aviez
des dents sur le palais les oiseaux non
plus ils en ont pas des dents sur le
palais les dinosaures non plus et
globalement les archosaures à part
encore une fois des trucs du trias un
peu barrés les archosaures ils n'ont pas
de dents sur le palais vous pouvez
ouvrir la tête d'un crocodile tant que
vous voulez et regarder dans sa bouche
il n'y a pas de dents voilà et les
oiseaux non plus bon ben là on a des
dents sur le palais donc c'est encore un
problème est par contre les lézards
encore une fois ils ont des dents sur le
palais mais le truc qui finit vraiment
de planter un clou c'est la dentition
pleuraux dont tu donc je n'y avais je
vous avait souligné dans la précédente
vidéo dans le précédent paléo news que
c'était pas que wang parler d'une
dentition pleuraux d'hondt alors que les
auteurs de l'article dans knight chez
eux disaient que la dentition était
accro d'hondt
il y avait un petit une petite subtilité
que je n'ai pas précisé c'est que la
condition accroc dont tu peut être
plaisir mort fiq donc primitive et donc
inutilisable pour la classification on
ne classe pas sur les caractère primitif
jamais donc il ya possibilité que cette
dentition accroc don de soi plaisir mort
fiq et donc non utilisables en
classification
on peut débattre de sa vous pouvez
débattre de ça dans les commentaires si
vous voulez si vous ne savez pas
pourquoi il ne faut pas classé en
utilisant lé caractère primitif
pensez par exemple aux yeux les reptiles
pondent des oeufs les mammifères n'en
compte pas donc l'ornithorynque est un
reptile voilà si cette phrase vient de
vous choquer vous venez de comprendre
pourquoi on ne classe pas avec les
caractère primitif
on classe avec les innovations
phylogénétique et il se trouve que les
d'amples euros dont tu
c'est une innovation phylogénétique une
innovation phylogénétique uniquement
trouver chez les lézards voilà comme les
iguanes par exemple typiquement les
iguanes ondes et d'amples remonte donc d
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pleuraux dont tu es bien là vous
avait donc la mâchoire inférieure ici
qui est sectionnée donc c'est ce que
vous voyez là la mâchoire inférieure et
sectionné vous avez de haut qui se
trouve de ce côté là le bas qui se
trouve de ce côté-là l'intérieur de la
bouche ici l'extérieur ici et en fait
quand une dent est accro dont elle se
trouve ici sur le haut de la mâchoire et
quand elle est plus heureux dont elle se
trouve là où elle se trouve actuellement
c'est à dire cette petite pointe qui se
trouve implanté sur l'intérieur la face
interne de la mâchoire dans une petite
goutte hier exactement comme les iguanes
donc s'efforcer fort probablement un
proche parent d iguane ou un lézard ou
quelque chose comme ça voilà c'est un
caractère c'est une innovation
morphologie künzi napo morphy pour ceux
qui connaissent le mot d donc voilà sept
dentition pleuraux d'hondt
elle est très très caractéristique de
pas les oiseaux les oiseaux évidemment
n'ont pas de dents fin pas les oiseaux
modernes mais les oiseaux anciens les
com espère ornis par exemple le ils ont
des dents qui sont sur le haut de la
mâchoire mais qui en plus ont une racine
donc c'est encore une condition
différentes qu'on appelle t caudan donc
ça a rien à voir donc voilà pleuraux
d'hondt égale reptiles et on finit comme
il se doit par un petit arbre
phylogénétique avec une reconstruction
de la tête de culotte avis c'est très
provocateur ça ça c'est quand même
vachement provocateur une reconstruction
de la tête docu lui nantes avis en petit
lézard voilà est ici bas voyez la
condition tecau dont elle est la voie la
condition pleuraux d'hondt sur
l'intérieur de la mâchoire avec le côté
la condition tecau d'autres sur le haut
de la mâchoire avec une racine et c'est
ce qu'on trouve chez les oiseaux et les
dinosaures et les crocodiles
donc voilà le occultantes avis c'est
fini il ne sera normalement plus
considéré comme le plus petit dinosaure
du monde puisque il s'agit d'un petit
lézard alata aux dimensions finalement
tout à fait banal pour un petit reptile
chao docu lui d'antalis et justement
puisqu'on des puisqu'on disqualifié au
cul lui dans ta viscom petit oiseau du
crétacé et bien il se trouve que pendant
ce temps là en belgique on en publie un
autre encore une fois dans hatcher
d'ailleurs
donc mon collègue essentiellement
britanniques que si je ne m'abuse
viennent de publier la découverte de
astéries ornis maïs trichet n 6
donc c'est un petit oiseau belge tout
petit oiseau le crâne est un peu à peine
plus gros qu'un pouce humains en gros
est ce qu'il ya de formidable avec
astéries ornis c'est que c'est un
parfait chaînon manquant
voilà je vais je vais énervé des gens à
utiliser le mot chaînon manquant
donc c'est un parfait intermédiaire
structurale voilà entre les en série
forme et légal inégalée y forment les
gallinacés bref entre les poulets
canards
voilà donc c'est un galet je sais plus
comment ils appellent ça un galet au en
série forme
où est ce qu'ils écrivent ça ah oui un
pan un pan de galop en sérail
voilà donc c'est le groupe dans lequel
on trouve les poules et les canards il
ya un petit arbre phylogénétique je vais
vous montrer
voilà donc les galliformes ils sont là
c'est les poules et les les en série
forme s'est lassé les canards et donc
bah il est il est en gros situé entre
les deux c'est un parfait petit chaînon
manquant pourquoi parce que son crâne ce
globalement celui d'une poule mais son
bec
vous pouvez voir qu'il a quand même un
petit peu du canari l'est pas encore
et allez aussi étalé sur le côté etc
mais il a déjà quand même un petit et
allemands ils allaient toutes ses
perforations qui rappelle beaucoup le
bec du canard donc voilà petit chaînon
manquant des familles entre les poules
et les canards qui confirme par là même
un clad qui avait été très discutée
justement celui réunissant les poules et
les canards voilà donc très belle petite
découverte et qui scelle la voilà au
moins il n'y a pas de doute sur le fait
c'est du très bon matériel et ça n'a pas
été collecté n'importe comment
contrairement à aucune vente avis et
puisqu'on parle de chez nomme encore
puisqu'on parle deux intermédiaires
structurale
voici une nouvelle publication sur helpe
histo steger à un poisson ou amphibiens
du dévonien comme vous voulez parce que
de toute façon il a il a les deux ans
lui j'ai envie de dire donc il a il a un
crâne d'amphibiens tout plat il n'a pas
de nageoire dorsale comme un amphibien
mais par contre vous voyez qu'il a une
belle nageoire caudale de belles
nageoires pelvienne et de belles
nageoires pectorales et que c'est un
mais c'est un magnifique spécimen
complètement préservée vous voyez cette
barre d'échelle fait un mètre donc en
plus il est balèze
contrairement à tiktaalik qui est
vraiment un tout petit animal qui tient
dans la main ou presque se tait et
lepisto steger il est balèze donc il a
été découvert au canada et comme je le
dis bah voila il a un corps de poisson
mais avec une tête d'amphibiens
tellement une tête d'amphibiens
d'ailleurs que c'est au père kull donc
et les trucs ou qui couvre les branchies
chez les poissons sont détachés donc par
définition forme déjà des épaules
puisque si vous ne le saviez pas mais
votre vos épaules sont en fait les
autres l'équivalent des opercules des
poissons donc il a déjà la tête séparée
des épaules comme un comme un amphibien
comme un animal terrestre mais il a
encore un corps de poisson il a même
encore les écailles voyait les écueils
ils sont magnifiques
préserver bon évidemment la photo est
pas aussi haute résolution qu'elle
devrait l'être
mais voilà et il a les yeux au sommet du
crâne dont qui chassait comme un
crocodile voilà c'est vraiment le
l'amphibien du dévonien typique mais
avec un corps de poisson quoi est ce qui
fait de l piste host et j'ai un truc
encore plus intéressant c'est la
présence de doigts et ça c'est sa
nageoire donc l'humérus sera du sud
radius ulna et là vous avez ce qui
correspondrait à la main normalement
c'est alors chez les ch et les trucs
comme tiktaalik c'est pas très bien
organisé il ya plein de choses dans tous
les sens et un chien tout ça mais chez
celui là il ya quand même
ces deux petits aux terminaux qui sont
pas lâchés tiktaalik et qui pourrait
correspondre au tour au doigt donc voilà
là il ya une représentation un peu plus
graphique si vous voulez et donc voici
ce que eux identifient comme étant les
doigts voilà les deux petits sauts que
je vous ai montré qu'ils sont en plus de
ce qu'on voit chez tiktaalik et qui
serait homologues audois des des
tétrapodes donc des amphibiens et puis
des reptiles et puis des mammifères ce
qui ferait des lepisto steger donc le
plus proche parent des tétrapodes voire
même un tétrapodes puisque les
tétrapodes sont définis par la présence
de doit donc elle pisto steger en fait
serait teinte et rappold avec un corps
de poisson et une tête d'amphibiens ce
qui fait de lui encore une fois un
parfait intermédiaire structurale à 12
et u
j'ai pas dis chaînon manquant voilà si
on vous demande maintenant où il est il
est où il est où le chaînon manquant
ben voilà il est là le chaînon manquant
il est là corps de poisson je veux dire
vous cacher la tête là vous cachez cette
partie là vous montrer le corps il est
bas c'est un fossile de poisson et là
vous montrer la tête c'est un amphibien
ouais bah c'est la même bête c'est la
même bestioles voilà et ça c'est beau
c'est beau quand la science produit des
choses comme ça c'est beau et pour finir
ce paléo news on va parler rapidement de
cette structure
cette structure c'est une c'est un
cercle
uniquement constitué d'ossements vieux
de vingt-cinq mille ans et qui est fait
d'ossements de mammouth et qui vient
d'être étudiée et ils ont réussi à
déterminer vous voyez tous ces points là
ce sont des sons des ossements de
mammouths et dans tous ses points ils
ont découvert 64 crâne de mammouth
ça veut pas dire qu'il ya 64 que y'a que
64 ce qu'elle est mais en tout cas il ya
au moins 64 crâne il possible qu'ils
aient plus de squelettes que ça et ça
c'est quand même assez impressionnant il
ya vingt-cinq mille ans pourquoi
pourquoi dans la sibérie il ya
vingt-cinq mille ans des gens ont fait
un grand cercle doucement dans la
toundra
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas il ya une
autre vue ici c'est assez c'est assez
impressionnant je ne sais pas j'ai lu
l'article et ils savent pas non plus
voilà en gros donc personne ne sait
réellement
qu'est ce que veut dire ce cercle alors
est-ce que c'était un garde-manger il ya
apparemment il ya de l'os brûlé à
l'intérieur alors est-ce que c'était un
garde manger est ce que c'était un
endroit où ils dépecer les animaux est
ce que on sait pas on n'en sait rien du
tout mais en tout cas c'est quand même
vachement impressionnant
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi et je vous dis
à très bientôt sur notre chaîne
ciao
bon
[Musique]